people who just you know look at by  matches with deep blue 20 years ago or  recent games are played by newer  machines in in God or in popular  videogame daughter they miss a very  important point that we in all these  cases though these games are different  and go for instance much more complex  than chess it's more abstract more  strategic so it's more difficult to  accumulate his sophisticated knowledge  as we did in chess but all these games  they represent closed systems which  means we humans field machine with was a  target with rules there's no automatic  transfer of the knowledge that machines  could accumulate in closed systems to  open-ended systems machines can do many  things and they will learn even more  things in the future but I don't see any  chance in the foreseeable future for  machines to ask the right questions now  they can ask questions but they don't  know what questions are relevant